climate activists around the world are
taking to the streets in the fourth
global climate strike today they're
demanding that governments step up their
efforts to further cut carbon emissions
now demonstrators in Australia kicking
off the day of protest planned in cities
around the world in Sydney hunters
skipping school for a rally outside the
City Hall in a March they were joined by
victims of the bush fires that have been
ravaging parts of Australia people have
lost their lives we have to ask how far
does this have to go before our
government finally takes action
unlike anything I've been through looks
like anything I've ever been through
an absolute firestorm that
I started investigating
exploring
okay the globe will climb and strike now
underway in Australia kicking off here
in Germany in a few hours time let's
talk about that now with climate
activist
Clara Meyer from the Friday's for future
movement in Germany good morning to you
Clara - see you again nice and early the
German parliament today is said to take
up a climate package it's been worked on
for a long time now but the Greens say
they want to see it toughened up they
want more provisions before they back it
what's wrong with the package as it
stands the problem is that it doesn't
actually target the or tackle the
problem of the climate crisis we need a
much higher co2 tax what is in that
climate package is basically like it's
it doesn't help us at all
May there are many aspects of it that
that will not help us with this issue at
all and we see this climate package as
basically like just an embarrassment of
the grand coalition okay uhm today is
not only Friday's for a future Green
Friday it's also Black Friday shoppers
across Germany going to be packing the
stores today your group has come out
against Black Friday why we believe that
instead of going shopping today and
spending a lot of money on a lot of
goods you could actually join our
protests and have fun on the streets
fighting for our future
okay now I'm in Paris protesters are
blocking access to the Amazon warehouse
today here in Germany are we expecting
anything like that
we're expecting a really great strike
especially in Berlin and a lot of people
showing solidarity on the streets with
the youth okay now it's not only
opposition to to shopping extravaganzas
like Black Friday the Friday's for
future movement has also come out
against cheap air travel big cars are
you concerned that you could face a
popular backlash at some point well our
goal is to actually change policies so
we want we don't only want to make
flying more expensive we want to cheap
and train travels so actually
we want to just take the method movement
that we have now and shift it something
else that is maybe even more convenient
for people so we hope that people will
support us and then travel with the
train through incentives by the grand
coalition let's say okay so to present
some options that you think that people
will like and and can so that they
support Friday exactly do you believe
that there are options there and we are
not using them and politics is not
supporting the usage of those
alternative methods of transportation
and we really have to change that okay
now the global climate conference starts
in Madrid next week ahead of that summit
the UN secretary-general Antonio
Guterres spoke to DW let's let's take a
listen what he had to say the
preservation is unsustainable
we are losing the race emissions are
growing there are two reports that were
recently published with the emissions
not being reduced we have the highest
concentrations of co2 in the atmosphere
only millions ago we had the same
situation but at the time with the
higher temperatures and a much higher
level of of the sea we have seen in the
todays emission gap report of unep that
we are risk we are at serious risk to
not be able to meet the limit of 1.5
degrees at the end of the century and
that would be catastrophic so it's time
to understand that we need to be much
more serious with political will to be
able to defeat climate change and Clara
guitars talking they are about a
catastrophic risk do you think that the
Friday's for future movement has the
momentum to address the problems that
Guterres is pointing to I believe that
if enough people actually will join us
then yes I believe that we have to come
together as a united and stronger force
to actually change policies to actually
address politics and that's what we're
doing today that's what we've been doing
for the last year and the fight will
continue okay have you noticed a
broadening of your ability to connect
with people compared to say the last
time we talked what was that a few
months ago yes I believe the
time we talked that was before the last
global strike and at that day nearly 1.5
million people turned out in Germany to
fight against the climate crisis to show
the government that they were not okay
with what was happening in this country
and in this world and we just see that
we're getting stronger we're getting
more powerful that people continue to
support us and that politics we'll have
to listen at us to us at some point okay
Clara my African for us today thank you
very much for coming in this morning
Clara thank you much